there are plenty of examples of what not
to do and a lot of these films
in my line of work you run into snakes
fairly often and you do have to be
careful you know snakes will come
cruising through an archeological site
and some people freak out and I run
after it and catch it and come back and
freak people out a little more a lot of
the destruction of Antiquities that
happens in in many of the different
films is something that we really tried
to avoid he is not patient he's not
patient at all in archeology is a
science of incredible patience the the
opening of the Ark of the Covenant is
not something you would do lightly
that's very impatient I know people who
have had to shoot it out with bandits
who've had graduate students kidnapped I
know people who've been kidnapped and
assaulted and when they start shooting
you shoot back nothing shocks me
scientists there is kind of a rush that
you get when you're holding an artifact
that no one's seen or touched in
thousands of years it is quite thrilling
I was a little let down by Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull first of all there are
no known civilizations like that in
South America a lot of the crystal
skulls that we know of appear to have
been manufactured in the modern era the
the first one is the best in the series
I think I like the third one too and
well you know hopefully number five will
be even better
you